what we're going to do in this video is
think about what properties of a shape
are preserved or not preserved as they
undergrow under undergo a transformation
in particular we're going to think about
rotations and reflections in this video
and both of those are rigid
transformations which means that the
length between corresponding points do
not change so for example let's say we
take this circle a it's centered at
point a and we were to rotate it around
point p point p is the center of
rotation and just say for the sake of
argument we rotate it
clockwise a certain angle so let's say
we end up right over
so we're going to rotate that way
and let's say our center ends up right
over here so our new circle the image
after the rotation might look something
like this and i'm hand drawing it so you
got to forgive
that it's not that well hand drawn of a
of a circle but the circle might look
something like this
and so the clear things that are
preserved or maybe it's not so clear and
we're going to hopefully make them clear
right now
things that are preserved under a rigid
transformation like this rotation right
over here this is clearly a rotation
things that are preserved
well
you have things like the radius
of the circle the radius length i could
say to be more particular the radius
here is 2. the radius here is also
is also two right over there
you have things like the perimeter well
if the radius is preserved the perimeter
of a circle which we call a
circumference well that's just a
function of the radius we're talking
about two times pi times the radius so
the perimeter of course is going to be
preserved in fact that follows from the
fact that the length of the radius is
preserved and of course if the radius is
preserved then the area is also going to
be preserved the area is just pi times
the radius squared so if they have the
same radius they're going to have all of
these in common and you can also that
feels intuitively right so what is not
preserved
not preserved and this is in general
true of rigid transformations is that
they will preserve the distance between
corresponding points if we're
transforming a shape they'll preserve
things like perimeter and area in this
case like instead of perimeter i could
say circumference circumference
so they'll preserve things like that
they'll preserve angles we don't have
clear angles in this picture but they'll
preserve things like angles but what
they won't preserve is the coordinates
coordinates
of
corresponding points they they might
sometimes but not always so for example
the coordinate of the center here is for
sure going to change we go from the
coordinate negative three comma zero to
here we went to the coordinate we went
to the coordinate negative 1 comma 2. so
the coordinates are not preserved
coordinates of the center
let's do another example with a
non-circular shape and we'll do a
different type of transformation
in this situation let us do
a reflection
so we have a quadrilateral here
quadrilateral
abcd
and we want to think about what is
preserved or not preserved as we do a
reflection across the line l so let me
write that down we're going to have
a
reflection in this situation
and we could even think about this
without even doing the reflection
ourselves but let's let's just do the
reflection really fast so we're
reflecting across the line x y is equal
to x so what it essentially does to the
coordinates is it swaps the x and y
coordinates but you don't have to know
that for the sake of this video so
b prime would be right over here a prime
would be right over there
d prime would be
right over here and since c is right on
the line l it's image c prime won't
change and so our new
when we reflect over
the line l
and you don't have to know for the sake
of this
video exactly how i i did that fairly
quickly i really just want you to see
what the reflection looks like the real
appreciation here is to think about well
what happens with rigid transformations
so
it's going to look something like this
the reflection
the reflection looks something like this
so what's preserved
and in general this is good to know for
any rigid transformation what's
preserved well side lengths that's
actually one way that we even used to
define what a rigid transformation is a
transformation that preserves the
lengths between corresponding points
angle measures
angle
measures
so for example this angle here the angle
a is going to be the same as the angle a
prime over here side lengths the
distance between a and b is going to be
the same as the distance between a prime
and b prime
perimeter
if you have the same side lengths and
the same angles then perimeter and area
are also going to be preserved just like
we saw with the rotation example these
are rigid transformations these are the
types of things that are preserved well
what is not preserved
not preserved and this just goes back to
the example we just looked at well
coordinates are not preserved so as we
see the image of a a prime has different
coordinates than a b prime has different
coordinates than b c prime in this case
happens to have the same coordinates of
c because c happened to sit on our the
line that we're reflecting over but d
prime definitely does not have the same
coordinates as d
so
most
of or let me say coordinates of a b
c or a b d
coordinates
of a
b
d not preserved
after transformation or their images
they don't have the same coordinates
after
trans
formation
the one coordinate that happened to be
preserved here is c's
coordinates because it was right on the
line of reflection and you could also
look at other properties of how it might
relate how different segments might
relate to lines that were not be trans
that were not being transformed so for
example right over here before
transformation cd
is parallel to the y-axis you see that
right over here
but after the transformation
c prime d prime so this could be
c prime d prime is no longer parallel to
the y axis in cast in fact now it is
parallel to the x
so when you have the relations to things
outside of the things that were
transformed that relationship might not
know that
those relationships may no longer be
true after the transformation